Jeremy Corbyn the first conferences
leader coming up do you back the idea of
Trident being discussed at this
conference I think it's going to be
discussed and I'm sure that the majority
of delegates both in the Union section
and the constricted section would want
to discuss I think that's a good idea of
conference ought to be the place where
there is open discussion that is the
whole function of it so a debate on
scrapping tried and pushed by labor CND
of which your chair there will be a
number of different views put forward I
am as everybody knows on the record as
opposing Trident and its replacement so
many of the shadow cabinet some some
voices in the defense team that maybe we
wouldn't we would have expected to serve
under your leadership are very much Pro
Trident did you not square off with them
that there would be no debate on this so
soon would that not have been sensible
at that time we weren't aware if there
was going to be debate a conference or
not though obviously all of us were
fully aware that it could well come up
yes it is an issue for debate I don't
know what the outcome of that is going
to be my own views are very well known
on nuclear weapons and they haven't
changed could you envisage situations
where the party policy is one thing and
you as leader don't vote for it oh
you're asking some hypothetical quest no
but they're important question because
this is a new politics and we're used to
the leaders Ritz running and you're sort
of saying that it might not all the time
you've decided some people who didn't
support you I would against you well I'm
grateful to all those colleagues that
took positions in the shadow cabinet and
all the other teams no influences were
made we have they said look we're not
completely seeing eye to eye on this
this and this I know we're not but we
can have that debate in that discussion
and many people are not going to quote
who said wow that's different but surely
isn't that what the public out there
want grown-up politics where people have
honest disagreements honest differences
of opinion you don't have to go to war
over it okay so we've had developments
in Syria that may be changing the game
and even in the past 24 hours there's
been a presumption that there'll be a
vote maybe that's a little less certain
would you say
the West should talk to Assad I have
huge differences with the sad I think
his human rights record is appalling I
think what the barrel bombs and all that
been done is absolutely appalling and I
would hope that we end up with a
completely different Syria does that
mean talks directly with him I doubt it
I think those would be proximity talks
via Russia they're already happening so
bringing Russia to the table with Iran
and all the the EU and USA actually
means in effect that voice is there it
is not necessary for us to go and talk
to him you seem to have come to a
compromise with your colleagues over
backing the European Union will you
campaign to stay in the EU yourself will
you go on streets and campaign to remain
in the EU as leader villain my position
is that if we stay in the EU and I think
the majority of British population want
to do that it's got to be on the basis
of a social Europe a very good
discussion last night with Alan Johnson
about how we're going to approach this
the party conference that possibly will
be debating this and we'll come to a
conclusion on it and I'm sure we're
gonna go around the road together
Nigel Faraj had what had been quite
excited about the idea of you
cultivating left-winger escapes Nigel
Farage and I are not close on anything I
think he's I think you said now that
because you're a left-wing cycling
vegetarian you're only going to attract
voters from the Green Party and this
idea that you can attract voters from
you Kip they're very happy and
comfortable with that what to make about
I'm not absolutely certain of everything
it goes through Nigel Ferraris mind what
I do know is that Nigel fried isn't
really offering any alternatives to
anybody on anything it's Nigel Farage
have a housing policy does he have a
health policy does he have an economic
policy is he actually offering any
solutions to young people stuck on low
pay or zero hours contracts or students
struggling with debt I'm not sure that
any elastic I'm not sure any of that
stuff appears on Nigel Farage's radar
let's let's move on Tim Farron at the
Lib Dem conference said that there were
some things that he found so egregious
about what was in the conservative man
affair
so there he'd be willing to break
parliamentary conventions and Salisbury
Convention and use his lords to block
things like the extension of right to
buy you've sort of thrown various
parliamentary conventions up in the air
since you became leader would he be
willing to use the House of Lords to
block conservative manifesto pledges
well our members in the House of Lords
are doing their very best to and will be
even more so to oppose the welfare
reform bill imposed a trade union bill
for all that it says in that is that a
breach the Salisbury Convention or not I
don't think it is and in any event is it
wrong that we should use whatever we can
to try and block what are measures that
can be truly appalling for ordinary
people in this country I wasn't aware
that Tim Farron had brought the
Salisbury Convention into play but thank
you so you you would consider on the
trade union bill we'd consider but it's
also of course the House of Commons has
to say so it's Conservative MPs are
going to have to go through make up your
mind time I know which way we're going
to be voting and I know which way I hope
all the opposition parties in be voting
on both those pieces of legislation
Jenna Coleman thank you very much thank
you